sorry Dust Brothers I'll probably
mistakenly tell everyone that the
chemical brothers did this soundtrack
all of this has got something to do with
the girl named Marla singer well not
really
right I mean I guess yeah something but
not something major she's basically a
buddy to one guy and a debate opponent
to the other she doesn't really do
anything to force the conclusion of this
movie between those huge sweating tits
and hung enormous the way you'd think of
gods is big I tend not to think of God's
memories much less the size no wonder
this movie lost at 10 Things I Hate
About You at the 1999 domestic
box-office the clips personal office
unit the hovertrax home acts or by
incredibly awesome consumer products
that are the tits and the best things
ever made are satirized for their empty
meaning in a movie full of Pepsi product
placement you want to see pain swing by
First Methodist Tuesday nights see the
guys with testicular cancer that's pain
this movie's entire plot kicks into gear
because the guys seeking drugs actually
took his doctor suggestion to attend a
testicular cancer meeting several days
later and actually remembered to go I'm
getting the sense that Brad Pitt is in
this movie and I'm getting thirsty all
of a sudden but I'm sure that's
unrelated well as you know she had a
first shot last week uh a girl I'm
uncertain whether to feel bad for these
poor bastards or take their misery as
gallows humor no wonder this movie lost
to Anna and the king at the 1999
domestic box-office discount Robert
DeNiro Sean Penn protagonist is a dick
to anyone who might wish to view the
support group scheduled movie breaks a
7-year streak of me forgetting about
Batman Returns shaking through that
light doesn't begin for another two
hours sir okay so what he can still go
through security and wait for the flight
right this is just the first of many
cheats the movie will commit on its path
to an admittedly badass conclusion movie
makes itself instantly unavailable for
in-flight viewing with fantasy plane
crash sequence life insurance pays off
triple if you die on a business trip its
movie never even once suggests that he
has anyone in his life at all that he
cares about enough to leave life
insurance for once which seems
the man for that particular job um
anyone seated in the exit row may be
called upon to perform emergency
procedures not just the window guy this
business card passing is only one of
many questions I have about this film's
final reveal these non first-class seats
have Hollywood levels of legroom okay so
we know by the end of this that Tyler
Durden is actually the narrator so how
is he stealing a car and checking on his
vibrating luggage at the same time now
he see him in a taxi coming back to his
apartment so he's he actually in the
stolen car or in the taxi massive
explosion in Norton's apartment manages
to keep Marla singer's phone number
completely unburned in fact it looks
like it purposely left it unburned
Norton calls the number on the front of
the card but why is there a completely
different number on the back of the card
if you asked me now couldn't tell you
why I call them maybe because after
Marla you literally don't know any other
people it's a topless bar despite there
being not one single boob in the entire
place let me tell you a little bit about
Tyler Durden unreliable narrator is
unreliable while the rest of us were
sleeping he worked here comes the funny
point in the movie where Tyler splices a
frame of a penis into a family film but
Norton just told us that while the rest
of us were sleeping he worked so what
family is going to a family film this
late in the hour if someone has to be
there to switch the projectors at the
exact moment that one reel ends in the
next one begins there were still
theaters that had to change reels back
in 1999 but this was not the norm and
the movie explains it like it was a
common occurrence he looked for it you
can see these little dots come into the
upper right hand corner of the screen
and it will ruin movies for you for life
until digital projection arrives this
port has always bothered me but the
total movie cheap for a cheap laugh why
the hell but this little girl be crying
when she has no idea she's even seen a
big cock even a hummingbird can catch
Tyler at work what does that even mean
hummingbirds are fast sure but they're
not detectives they're odd amazing
little freaks of nature who move quickly
but the statement still makes no fucking
sense
this catering company allows its waiters
to wear Walkmans and listen to music
while providing top-notch attended
dinner service so is this really
happening in full view of the customers
or is it even happening at all again I
asked if these people are normal people
wouldn't they just walk right up to Ed
Norton and ask why he's kicking his own
ass thereby revealing the secret to him
instead the movie has Tyler say hey to
the onlookers and then it cuts away as
though nothing awkward was said
afterwards so I graduate I call it not
long distance I said
he says get a job same here
you too didn't you just say that you
didn't know your dad and your dad left
when you were six are you inventing a
backstory for Tyler or a backstory for
you can I get the icon in cornflower
blue
absolutely efficiency is pride a number
one people how in the holy land of is
giving this asshole the same icon in a
different stupid shade of blue part of
the model of efficiency ham sandwich is
375 the ham sandwich with cheese is 370
Eve something so at most four cents more
than the same sandwich without cheese
the first rule of Fight Club is you do
not talk about Fight Club haha what a
silly rule or wait is that the point
dammit no wonder this movie lost a deuce
Bigalow male gigolo with the 1999
domestic box-office second rule of Fight
Club is you do not talk about Fight Club
hilarious repeated rule that becomes the
film's most memorable piece of dialogue
goes utterly unenforced the entire movie
and in fact the movie would be
impossible if it was even remotely
adhered to but Ricky was a God for ten
minutes when he trounced the maitre d of
a local food court they have maitre d's
at food courts yeah like William Shatner
discount winner Nimoy self-improvement
is master bitch then I am super self
improved wait despite the rules we made
such a fuss about Fight Club continues
growing at an exponential rate movies
sex scene with fake nudity is both
awesome and creepy this is my house what
are you doing in my house to keep the
illusion going for the audience Marla
helpfully says yeah instead of we were
putting all night long don't you
remember
somebody was it you the cops in this
apartment complex you've been on the
phone with Tyler Edward Norton the whole
time my god I haven't been like that
since grade school
man that line is so freakin awesome we
have to knock us in off and by awesome I
mean disturbing as fuck so yeah is he
really having sex with Marla and
imagining himself doing situps on the
floor down below or is he actually doing
sit-ups and imagining Tyler having sex
with Marla so he's the one that turns
off the electricity during the rainstorm
and it really goes out so he's real
right now so why is she screaming his
phone call is another instance of the
narrator we see on-screen being
physically real while Marla is
apparently upstairs moaning - a vibrator
she comes over but only to masturbate
upstairs while he washes clothes in the
kitchen except for they're humping Tyler
and Marlow
never in the same room from what I've
seen it appears dial and Marla aren't
even in the same room during that either
the saw that has to be just right the
best time for explaining the details of
the plan is during execution of said
plan while security guards are nearby
okay so again we just saw Tyler get his
face pounded in by Lou a minute ago so
how does Norton basically have a clean
face right now he still has the bandage
on his right hand from the LIBOR and
earlier so his face should look like
it's in total disrepair right now Tyler
dreamed up new homework assignments he
handed them out and sealed envelopes
well Fight Club escalated quickly
what waiting getting out of all this is
this making you happy character
accidentally chooses his words carefully
to avoid being spoiled on his double
life too early the director said let's
have Tyler eating an apple in this scene
it'll make him look like even more of a
non-existent asshole I know we need
transition shots but where is he coming
from right now he doesn't have a job
anymore and we've literally not seen him
spend any time away from Tyler on his
own away from this house since they
became friends so where was he was it
just so we can have this little he finds
out there's all kinds of going on he
doesn't know about scene cuz I feel like
it is movie that has been shamelessly
advertising Pepsi shamelessly shows us
an actual Pepsi ad did they paint that
huge circle and semicircle on the
building when Tyler and crew have done
if this dude had a larger bladder can we
call this urine ex machina do a movie
you clearly showed the narrator in the
ballroom following the other waiters
cluelessly but now apparently he was
physically in the bathroom the whole
time ask Tyler and even if there's some
magic wand explanation for that but
you're telling me not only to Tyler know
this dude was gonna need to pee at some
point tonight but he knew exactly when
Edward Norton gets to beat the fuck out
of Jared Leto which is what all of us
wanted to do in the 90s after my
so-called life and well into the next
century for thirty Seconds to Mars and
oh by the way he's the only one who
ended up winning an Oscar out of this
group before you die paint a
self-portrait build a house how do they
know when to talk and when not to talk
how do I know which questions to answer
and which ones not the answer
he's clearly talking to himself and
answering his own questions Tyler's
version of hitting rock bottom and
letting go means letting go of the wheel
but putting on your seat belt so you
don't get hurt how does this dilapidated
house support all this electricity and
sheer number of people this building was
close to falling down with one person
pretending to be two people living in it
and when he first got here he said
turning on
another light in the house went out we
were supposed to kill two birds one
stone
destroy a piece of corporate art and
trash a franchise coffee bar asshole
Project Mayhem Army guys had strictly
kept it that don't talk about Project
Mayhem rule until now because the
audience needs to know what's going on
also there can't be more than one place
in all the world where it would be
possible to do these two things at once
so let's all think on for the convenient
giant ball corporate art installation
and it's convenient location otherwise
Tyler's assignment is unfollow the shot
Bob wait the cops are right there
shooting and you still managed to
retrieve the massively heavy corpse of
Bob without also getting shot yourselves
was I asleep had us left well I was my
theory especially when the movie kept
hitting it so strongly but I'm still at
a loss to explain those scenes where you
were listening to Tyler fuck Marla or I
suppose all the scenes where you
literally interact with Tyler how are
you blacked out but not blacked out at
the same time so I mean I kind of give
up that aroma of old sweat like fried
chicken
hmm old sweat you broke your promise if
we can talk to her bum hello no he
didn't actually he just asked a few
vague questions and never once said
anything about Tyler Durden she talked
about Tyler Durden because we're the
same person this is one of those great
mind folks of course it's another reason
why we love this movie so much but one
question how is he never snapped into
his normal self in the middle of doing
all this other he's been doing his Tyler
Durden he's fine as long as he's in his
hometown but when he travels he's
suddenly Tyler all the time man Pepsi
had this movie by the balls and I can't
figure out if it's ironic or not the
anti corporate message of the movie
comes from disreputable sources but
we're supposed to laugh at the empty
consumerism throughout the movie I
wonder this movie lost a stigmata at the
1999 domestic box-office oh how lucky is
that they shot this on the day seven
years in Tibet was in theaters guy in
boxer shorts with a gun gets all the way
from interrogation room out the front
door the police station because reasons
oh my this cop car has yellow lights or
this towing and or parking security
vehicle has audible sirens either way
once in let's leave the super-secret
underground van bomb unlocked all the
way up until detonation
cool cool bro good idea but since when
is Project Mayhem about murder the
buildings are empty not killing anyone
yeah about that you're about to blow up
ten buildings in a huge city with
thousands of people driving and walking
everywhere did you somehow find a way to
make sure people weren't doing that the
bomb clock went from 25 50 to 25 45 and
a record slow time of 24 seconds your
dude I've seen what a gallon of milk or
water looks like you do not have 400
gallons of anything in the back of that
van
yeah no he's dead now how does shoot
yourself in the cheek kill your
imaginary friend in the back of the hand
without also killing you ever since
cinemasins began the most requested
thing has been TV since and now it's a
reality click the link in the
description below to check it out and
now the audio outtakes have a nice
display you do not talk about Fight Club
third rule of Fight Club
no matter what a stripper tells you
there's no sex in the champagne room I
mean look at you
you domesticated yourself for this girl
no you took yourself out of life you've
walked a fine line for her and the
minute you want a little of it back she
walks out on you just like the saying
says you know in the poker game of life
women are the rake they are the rake
when the matrix was first built there
was a man born inside who had the
ability to change whatever he wanted
to remake the matrix as he saw fit it
was he who freed the first of us taught
us the truth
goddamn Jim how long you have too few
days you don't look too good
yeah don't feel too good either Matt can
send me me killing him like a monkey
ready to be shot into space semilla I
was gonna leave the army of the 12
monkeys into the pages of history
forever even occur to me
[Music]
say it because we're the same person
well good for you art I was gonna let it
go you was looking so happy just now I
was thinking mmm but to tell you the
truth I'm glad you figured it cuz I have
been dying to tell you